Hello, everyone. Just getting people admitted here and we will start in just a second.
Right. We're going to share the screen so you should be able to see that.
All right. I hope that everybody had a good couple of weeks.
Since the last time we chatted on a Monday and hopefully you're having a good day today.
So we will get into it. A few questions came in.
All right. The first question here is regarding the first ones regarding vitamin C.
So this person is ultimately asking somebody that they spoke with.
Okay. I think that the screen just shared. I just got a little pop up.
So hopefully you guys can see everything. And hear me. I don't think I'm muted.
I think everything should be working. Send me a chat if something is off.
Okay. So vitamin C.
She was taking her daughter somewhere for allergies and.
And the practitioner there told her that most vitamin C is sourced from corn.
And that is true. Most synthetic vitamin C that you would buy, you know what?
Target or Walmart or something is sourced from from GMO corn. So it is is synthetic.
So that is true. And she says she has two different forms. One is a scorbic acid rose hips.
And then it's got some fillers and magnesium. The other one is made from organic.
Acerella extract organic tart cherry and you know a number of of whole foods ingredients making up this supplement for natural vitamin C.
So ultimately she's asking do I need to be concerned with what is in these products or where they're sourced from.
Is it important to get to just get the vitamin C not sure about getting enough from food alone.
So sourcing is important, you know, and it depends on, you know, what you're striving for.
There's kind of more of a side of perfection. And then there's, you know, just convenience.
So a scorbic acid, which is the synthetic form.
We do have some vitamin C products on our shelves that we sell that are made from a scorbic acid.
So ultimately it's not the best source, but it is a source of vitamin C.
It would be best if we're looking for perfection or what is better to give vitamin C from a whole food sources.
So if I had to pick one option one or two of what you've presented, I would pick option two, the whole foods based vitamin C.
And that is not the scorbic acid. So, you know, and certainly it's not a horrible thing to take a scorbic acid.
Like I said, we do have some products that use the scorbic acid.
So just getting vitamin C is a good thing. If you're on it kind of long term as a daily thing, then I certainly would try to get the version that is more whole food space.
But if you're taking it short term because you have, you know, onset of cold-like symptoms, then whatever you have, if it's a scorbic acid, you know, just take it.
It's not going to, you know, not going to harm you, but just long term.
And if you're taking it longer term, then I would try to choose a more organic whole foods based product.
Put a picture of this camel camel powder up because this is also very high in vitamin C.
And you can add this to smoothies, obviously it's a powder.
One teaspoon has 760% of the recommended daily allowance for vitamin C.
So you certainly can use this source. And if you're using, you know, this second vitamin here, other whole food sources, you're getting plenty of vitamin C to help boost the immune system.
And that is what I would prefer over that first option.
The next question has to do with sauerkraut. This was recommended for Tim.
She's been buying the type in the bag for fermentation, but it does contain sodium bensinate and sodium by sulfite for preservatives. Is this okay?
So some preservatives, you know, are okay. These two do happen to be on a little bit of the list of less.
Okay, they're not great.
You know, it depends on how often he's eating it. And if again, we're trying to, you know, be conscious of ingredients and choose better options, then this sauerkraut would be a better option.
So this is called wild brine. And I've highlighted the website here. You certainly can order it off the website wild brine.com.
Otherwise, if you have a Costco near you, they sell it to at Costco.
You know, so you can get it there as well. But this is just an organic, an organic source of sauerkraut that doesn't have those preservatives in it.
So look for that. The other thing I was going to mention is I use a number of different apps to kind of help me at the grocery store or help me just with ingredients in general.
So I certainly don't know all of the additives or things on an ingredient list that are not good for you.
It's a good idea. And so I do look at the label and the ingredient list. And if there's a lot of things that I can't pronounce or I'm not sure what they are, then I look for a better option.
Ultimately, I'm looking for, you know, just whole food sources, things that I can understand. I don't want a lot of preservatives. I don't want a lot of sugar.
You know, you don't want a lot of food dies or natural flavors, those types of things. Now, nobody is perfect. And certainly we all have times very rich for convenience foods. And they might, you know, not have the greatest list of ingredients.
But to help me when I am at the grocery store, I use an app called Bobby approved.
And I also follow this gentleman on Instagram. He has an Instagram account called Flav city F L A V E C I T Y and I have learned a lot from him just about ingredients in general things to look for.
And he has an app. It's called Bobby approved. It's kind of a teal green color. It's got a thumbs up with a big B in the center of it. And you can scan items and it will give you a rating.
You can also look at ingredient lit ingredient list. So it gives you a list of, you know, just common additives, fillers, things that you might see on a label. And it gives them a rating. So green is obviously good or go ahead. Yellow is, let's hesitate a little bit. Think about this. Maybe it's okay and small doses.
And then red is really something that you don't want. Or if it's red, sometimes it's because of the conventional version of it. For example, chicken is listed on there.
The conventionally farm raised chicken, you know, is loaded with, you know, just different hormones, steroids, you know, just all of these things to really make the chicken plump up fast.
It's just in confined in farms that are, you know, it doesn't see the light of day. It's just unhealthy chicken, which leads to unhealthy meat that we are then consuming, you know, and then they're fed GMO grain and corn. And so anything that that animal is eating, then we are ultimately consuming when we eat that animal.
Chicken is listed as a red option. However, organic, you know, pasture raised chicken would be fine to eat a better option. So check out his app.
It goes through different stores, so common stores and he has, you know, the best things that you can find in those stores, Trader Joe's Costco, all the, you know, whole foods.
So it gives you an idea of some examples of good things to buy at these stores. You can scan a barcode and see if if it's in his database, and if it gives you a rating, then you can look at that ingredient list that I talked about of, you know,
just common things that you might find on the label. And you can just educate yourself. And again, nobody is perfect. I certainly am not perfect. But with a little bit of education, you can find better healthier options. He also has a cookbook. So he's just great to follow again. I've learned a lot from him. So utilize that.
If you would like. And then the last question here is regarding going number two. So some constipation says sometimes he may spend an hour in the bathroom and she's saying that she has taken food grade bentonite clay and psyllium husk, mix them together with water and it helps her, you know, have a ball movement.
So would this be something our patient could try. Yes, absolutely. So he can try any of those.
There is the section in your binder in the gut health section that does go through constipation. And so we have a list of things that you can try.
So one of our main go to things is this phase six assist. So this is our private label of super allos. So some of you may have super allo 250 that you're using. So this is just our private label version of that. And that is kind of our number one go to supplement anytime somebody is struggling with constipation.
You would just take one capsule at night before bed. And this really provides some great relief for constipation. And then certainly moving, you know, staying hydrated eating fiber, you may also be taking this on spectrum or the SBI protect those things can help as well.
So just try different things. And certainly these things that you mentioned can be a great support as well.
All right, the next question here.
Can you explain the role of our liaison. I'm not always sure where to go with questions and concerns besides the zoom calls.
So yes, so the role of the liaison is kind of a fluid role, meaning it's, it has evolved. It's a little bit changed.
So depending on when you started with us, you may have had more of a one on one with your liaison, whether it was myself or Ashley, where you're working through everything with that person specifically.
And in the last handful of months, we've kind of evolved the role of the liaison and really everything that we do here as a clinic. So we're taking more of a team approach, so you might not be assigned a specific individual liaison.
All hands on deck, everybody at the clinics, or we're all helping with rife, we're helping with getting out of the membership site, helping with the binder, you know, genetics and all of these pieces.
But the main way that you are going to get your questions answered is the zoom calls. So we have the binder review. So questions regarding the binder.
Are to be asked on that zoom call, rife questions on the rife zoom call genetic questions on the genetic zoom call and then you have two opportunities per week.
So the Monday Q&A and then the Wednesday with Dr. Connors to answer other questions.
The liaison, you know, you certainly can email either myself or Ashley, if you have a clarification question regarding, you know, supplements or, you know, a specific diet question, I forget, can I have this, can I not have this, you know, and that would be appropriate for the zoom call as well, because everybody might have, you know, we get a lot of nutrition and diet questions.
The question that individual has regarding that can be helpful for everyone. So the goal of the zoom calls is really to be a service and help to everyone in this kind of educational setting.
We've had to kind of change our approach a little bit, just because we have been contacted by the Minnesota board. I don't some of you have have known that Dr. Connors has mentioned that before and in order to kind of keep practicing what we're doing, continue our mission to help serve as many people as possible.
So I'm going to take this more educational approach versus one on one individual care. So zoom calls number one way to get your questions answered.
And again, you have all of these opportunities to jump on a couple times a week. So any question, there's nothing that is off limits.
If you do want to speak with Dr. Connors or myself individually about something specific and you just want that personal contact, then, then call the clinic and get them, get on the schedule for that.
Hopefully that helps, you know, kind of define what a liaison is really the liaison is the person that can help guide you. It's your contact person to help guide you with care in the clinic, help clarify things point you in the right direction.
You know, if it's just a quick quick question, you know, we certainly can answer an email, but most questions, we do defer to the zoom calls so they can be addressed in that fashion. So just keep submitting your questions through this platform.
Nothing is off limits. So don't be shy or afraid to ask a specific question.
And then we have the question, which is my husband has do add no carcinoma and has had five rounds of chemo out of eight. He's starting to experience some neuropathy and the oncologist is watching that. My question is, what a lower dose of chemo be a good idea.
And if so, in your opinion, what percentage would still be helpful. So unfortunately, that's asking for medical advice. And so we can't, we can't answer the question, what a lower dose of chemo be a good idea.
I don't know for this person individually, you know, it's really a conversation that you have to have with the oncologist and together with the oncologist make that decision. Now, certainly from a large scale concept approach. Yes, chemo is what is inducing this neuropathy and so potentially a lower dose of chemo.
Would be would lessen the effect of the neuropathy. Now what it's going to do to the, you know, for cancer purposes. Again, you have to discuss that with your oncologist. Maybe it's good idea. Maybe it's not a good idea. Maybe they want you to power through.
So bring that up with the oncologist. My questions to you would also be, are you following our chemo protocol. We do have a chemo protocol that is designed to help protect healthy cells.
So really healthy cells are more resilient than cancerous cells. And so we have a protocol that you know it involves a number of different things, but essentially a 24 hour water fast prior to chemo administration. So that your cells are starving again healthy cells are more resilient than cancer cells so they can bounce back from this kind of starving scenario better than a cancerous cell.
So then when you do go and have your chemo therapy infusion because your cancer cells are unstable, you know, they don't like being starving. They are going to uptake that chemo more readily more quickly than your healthy cells that are a little more resilient.
So that fast is to help the target chemo to help the chemo target the cancerous cells. And then it's protective to your healthy cells. And then, you know, there are certain things that we don't want you to do 48 within that 48 hours from administration of chemo through that 48 hours.
We don't want you to do a lot of detoxing. We don't want you to take specific liver support supplements. We really want the chemo therapy to do what it's supposed to do target those cancer cells. And it really does what it is going to do within that first 24 or excuse me 48 hours.
So then after that 48 hour mark you really want to hit the detoxing really hard. So add back, you know, your some detoxing foot baths add back those coffee anima's the castor oil packs add back any of the liver support supplements that you were holding off on.
So really hit the detoxing hard and that's going to pull as much chemo therapies possible from the system again to help protect the healthy cells because after that 48 hour mark.
It's really not doing anything else to the cancer cells. It's really just starting to harm your healthy cells. So if you don't have the chemo protocol.
And you're not doing that then reach out to your liaison myself or Ashley and we can email you the protocol and so that can be helpful.
And then Dr. Connors has a blog post regarding chemo and juice neuropathy. So you might want to check that out. So if you just do a search from our website.
You know, chemo and neuropathy or just search neuropathy and you can find information that could be helpful. And then these are some of the things that you can choose to do, you know, to help to help offset, you know, the chemotherapy and the neuropathy.
So be encouraged that you can rebuild nerve pathways.
You know, so, so if you're struggling with this, it can be reversed.
Again, you know, here's an image of the foot bath. So do your foot bath detoxing sessions.
You're your programs that we created for you as far as the foot bath is concerned, really are targeting your cancer.
So their cancer fighting frequencies. So I would look in the general eye on pro wave folder and look for some detoxing ones to help after that 48 hour mark of the chemo infusion.
So look for detoxing foot bath programs that you can run.
This is a rebuilder. So this is a therapy. It is available on our website.
This is something that does help stimulate nerve pathways. So stimulate with frequencies specific nerve pathways to help rebuild them.
So we use it in a tub. So it's filled with water. There's a little frequency generators that are going into the tub.
It is different than the eye on pro wave. But this, this is a tool that you can definitely use to help rebuild the nerve pathways.
This is specifically designed and tested for neuropathy. So that can be a great therapy. You can look that up on our website.
This is a small image of the PEMF machine. So the PEMF machine can be a great support as well. It's, you know, ultimately, policy, electro, magnetic field therapy. So it works to help with cellular health.
It's basically a form of cellular exercise. So that can be super helpful for neuropathy for many things.
Obviously, if we're exercising ourselves, we're getting ourselves to operate at a higher frequency.
When our cells are healthy and operating to the best of their ability, they can perform all of those functions that we want them to do, you know, detox rebuild, break things down, recycle things, get rid of things.
And so they can, the PEMF machine can help rebuild nerve pathways. You would maybe just want to put the paddles on your feet or your hands or wherever you're really struggling with neuropathy.
And do it that way versus putting it over the center area. Usually we put the paddles over the center, the abdominal area for doing just kind of a whole body treatment, but you can put those pads on your feet to help stimulate those nerves directly.
Now, a lot of chiropractic clinics may have a PEMF machine. So you might want to do a search. You can do a search for pulse PULSE certified.
And that is the machine that we use in the clinic. So this is a professional machine.
So if you do that search for PULSE certified, there's a location finder. So you may be able to find locations near you that offer PEMF therapies. You can call them up and see if you can get on on this schedule for some therapies. You might want to do two times a week, you know, and, you know, for a few months, really throughout the rest of your chemo sessions.
And then after chemo is done to help rebuild. So that is an option. We do have a home PEMF unit that is available on our web store.
I forget it is, you know, it is a professional therapy equipment. So it is spending, but it can really be helpful for neuropathy, certainly other things as well. So a great tool to have if you are looking for something else to bring into the home. So that's an option.
And certainly be vitamins. So I have this image here. Sorry, it's a little bit small, but be specific naturally is our whole food based be vitamin and be vitamins have been known to help help with nerve pain and help kind of rebuild nerve pathways.
This does not have B12 in it. So you might also want to add a B12 supplement typically we're using pro hydroxyl cabalamin as our B12, but the B specific naturally has all of the other forms of B vitamins. So the vitamins can be helpful.
So circle back with your oncologist, you know, kind of get details on if a lower dose would still be beneficial because it certainly could help prevent continuation of neuropathy or further nerve damage, but but definitely get on some of these things.
And the other thing too is just the general rife programs, I don't know of one specifically off the top of my head right now for nerve healing, but certainly you should be able to find a nerve healing bulb frequency program as well that you can try. So there, there's a lot of things that we can do to help with neuropathy so don't feel like this is a permanent thing.
We can we can help with that.
Okay, my husband is set to have a CT scan in October six months after his Whipple and six rounds of oxyplatin and Zalota we what should we expect and should he be taking something to offset the radiation on CT scan.
So what should you expect as well, certainly, you know, after surgery and chemotherapy, we would expect to hopefully see reduced reduction in tumor size, I'm not sure with the surgery, you know, really able to get all of the tumor, was there any residual, you know, tumor remaining, I'm not sure.
But if there was anything remaining certainly, you know, hope and pray that that, you know, is shrinking or maybe it's gone, maybe it's not detectable anymore.
Any shrinking, obviously is is great news, even if a if a tumor is stable, that is great news as well, if it's not growing, that's good.
So stable or reduction in size, you know, those are the goals, that's what we would hope for, those are all good signs.
If it is continuing to grow, then, you know, obviously revisit with your oncologist, what the next steps would be as far as as, you know, anything conventional.
But certainly, let us know of the results as well and we can certainly help guide you obviously with everything possible within the natural realm, you know, within our scope of practice, we can retest supplements, we can, you know, read, look at frequencies, see if we need to change anything.
Yes, absolutely, he should be taking the radiation, homeopathic droppers to help pull the radiation from his, from the tissue, he can start that, you know, a few days to a week before the CT scan.
And then I would just continue until that bottle is gone, so there's instructions on the bottle, how to take it, I believe it's three drops two times a day is a homeopathic dropper, so you do want to make sure you're taking that away from food.
Food, you don't want any mint, you know, spear mint coffee, so some of these food items that can have higher energy or higher frequency that may interrupt or distract from the homeopathic dropper, so anytime you're using a homeopathic therapy, you want to do it on an empty stomach.
And again, that's the radiation homeopathic dropper, so you can just search for that on our store and I would definitely start him on that.
All right, next question, have you ever heard of enter a medical drink to help relieve the effects of chemo, if so have you heard of people finding relief using it.
I have never I've not heard of this specific product, so I am not familiar with it and I don't know of anybody who has used it or found relief, so I apologize, I'm maybe Dr. Connors has heard of it, certainly you could ask on the Wednesday's call my thoughts on this are a medical drink.
I'm just not quite sure that raises the red flag for me, I'm going to assume that it's you know synthetic ingredients, I'm not sure what it is but to help relieve the effects of chemo so maybe for nausea, maybe for fatigue, maybe for
chemo, brain, I'm not quite sure so so my thought on this is you really want to get in antioxidants you want to get in certain amino acids to help you know kind of rebuild muscle so you want to just you know get foods foods are kind of the best sources to get your nutrients.
The greens first product that we have most of our patients on i'm not sure if this patient specifically is on but the greens first supplement is whole food based nutrition so you're getting just tons of super fruit super vegetables you're getting some probiotics you're getting some enzymes to help with digestion.
So if you're not taking that I would start taking that and I would if you're only taking one scoop a day maybe take two scoops a day so that can help you get those that those nutrients in to help relieve side effects certainly some minerals could be depleted and so you could take you know multi mineral.
We use multi men plus and that's you know the best form so when we're talking about minerals, we need to be sure we're paying attention to the form because there are some forms that are not so great for the body we want forms that are bound to specific substances the way that nature you would find them in nature because that's the way that your body recognizes them and can utilize them appropriately so.
So our multi men's plus are the multi minerals in that correct form so I would maybe try taking that if you're looking for you know kind of an additional source of liquid nutrition I know.
Kate farms is a product that is organic it's whole foods you know already kind of prepared for you so you could look up Kate farms K A T E F A R M S and that is a good source of organic whole food nutrition so a lot of people use that you know if they are on you know a liquid diet or a tube fed.
They're getting their nutrition from a tube versus some of the things that they would give you and in the hospital that again are just all synthetic and they're just not great for the body so Kate farms would be a good source of food organic food based liquid nutrition and then certainly some of the things that you have.
In the home the greens first double up on that maybe get some extra minerals and hopefully that would alleviate some of the side effects of chemo and then again that chemo protocol goes through a number of different things that you can start to implement there are some additional supplements in there to help rebuild the integrity of the cell membrane that phosphatidal calling or body bio PC product is something to really help the maintain the integrity of the cell membrane.
Because when you're taking chemo you're literally are killing cells and so we want to protect those healthy cells so we can reinforce healthy cells with that body bio PC supplement you know we've got supplements to help boost the immune system supplements to help with liver support again after that 48 hour mark so take a look at that if you don't have the chemo protocol.
Okay, maybe I'm going to check in with some of the chat questions here before we start on the next one what apps please.
So the app that I was referring to was called Bobby approved that is the one that I mentioned so it's kind of a tealish bluish green color and it's got a thumbs up icon and then the letter B in the middle of that thumbs up.
So check that out another one that's not necessarily food based but it's product based would be you can do a search for the think dirty app THI N K D I R T Y so that's an app where you can scan personal care products cleaning products so more product based and it will give you a toxic toxicity rating based on the ingredients there.
So the lower the score, the lower in toxicity, the better the products so that could be helpful as well so check those out and if you need need a reminder of these or you can't find them just reach out and I can send them to you the right protocols have options for neuropathy okay perfect I knew they did I just don't know the exact names of them but definitely if you you know just search in the general.
List of programs for neuropathy I'm sure there are a number of programs are even nerve healing there is a program called accelerated healing that's in the normalizing frequencies folder and that that could be helpful to so check that out.
All right and then another let's see since the Navarro HCG tests are on hold due to supply shortage shortages besides CT scans etc are there other ways to test cancer progressions.
Regressions so tumor marker tests so I would do the blood tests definitely and sometimes you know people can have a cancer diagnosis and tumor markers for that specific cancer may not be elevated so it's not there's no one perfect test but there's just a number of different tests that might be wise to kind of try to track in a number of different ways.
So you could do the blood draws so the tumor marker test and in your binder there's information on tumor marker tests just be in tune with how you feel.
Certainly if there's symptoms you know energy depletion and energy depletion and appetite constipation pain.
You know fatigue inability to sleep you know stress just fear you know all of these things are signs and so pay attention to just your physical symptoms and check in with us you know we can help with some of those we can certainly do a retesting with the cheek swab we can do a reassessment.
Any other test well you're saying besides the typical conventional scan so there are other ways to test.
There is a scan that is called I believe it's called Prenuvo but I don't know that it's really nationwide I know that they and I haven't checked on it in a number of months but they do have a scan so it's basically an MRI.
It's like an MRI equipment that they're using but they're not using that same technology and if you do a search for it you know there's no radiation it's not harmful but it can give you a look either full body or in an individual area.
So Prenuvo P-R-E-N-U I believe it's N-U-V-O you can look for that I know they have places in California and they have places in Minnesota so Minneapolis actually has a place they are spending though the drawback is that they are spending but sometimes you're a person that you just need data.
And so maybe it's worth it for you I think a full body scan you know a number of months ago was $2500 but it's an option so not harmful to the body but you do have to be lying still so it is like an MRI lying still for you know 45 minutes to an hour but you can check that out other than that and I don't know of any other you know kind of none.
So if you have a toxic non invasive ways if you can do ultrasound if you have a tumor that can be you know kind of checked based on ultrasound to see size and ultrasound is is not harmful so you can check that out.
C-A-F-L frequency 6019 and 6020 are helpful for nerve disorders and neuropathy and nerve healing so this is in I don't know if this was chatted to everyone or it might have just been to me it looks like it was to me let me see if I can copy this and paste it so you guys can see this.
So just kind of a source for some additional nerve help so you can take a screenshot of that C-A-F-L frequency the number 6019 and 6020 are helpful for nerve disorders and neuropathy and nerve healing and then here's.
Here's a URL you can check out pulse frequency dot com frequency dash lists so you can screenshot that and you can do a little search for that so thank you for posting that hopefully that can be helpful for people.
In our case Patricia has no symptoms so yeah sometimes it's hard to track based on symptoms because you don't even have any symptoms when you went in and suddenly came out with a cancer diagnosis so yes that is hard.
But if you suddenly have some symptoms then you know then you would know to all right we need to pay attention to this let's check in.
So yes it can be hard to track when you don't really have symptoms but I'm glad you don't have symptoms nobody wants to have those symptoms so that's a good thing certainly you know again the tumor marker tests checking in with us to do those re evaluations you know ultrasound and you know we just do the best that we can.
Thermal imaging yes absolutely so thermography is a great way to you know kind of track track and monitor some cancers it's not you know a great way for all cancer you can't really determine.
You know size of maybe like a liver lesion or you know stomach or any digestive lesions it is a good way to track for breast tumors it's really the thermography is really great for breast scanning can give you ideas of where there.
There might be inflammation throughout the body so there's a number of things that thermography is great for and can be used you know as a way to kind of track and measure for breast tumors but it's not a super great tracking method for all tumors.
Okay I think that was all the chats for now so we'll put that aside okay so my day of diet states in the binder that I can eat apples and carrots yet I understand they have a high sugar content which feeds cancer please explain so.
When you're looking at your binder we've kind of identified the drivers for each individual's cancer you know so this is this is our thoughts and this is our approach this doesn't mean you know all our testing is foolproof now certainly all cancer is fed by sugar in some fashion.
But sugar might not be the main driver for your cancers so if your main driver is dairy or it's more amino acid based then you don't have to be as careful with the sugar.
We still need to be careful across the board but if sugar is not your main driving fuel for your cancer you don't need to be as strict if your sugar is the main fuel then yes we need to be more strict so depending on what we've kind of identified.
Would determine you know do I need to be more careful of apples and carrots or can I ease up on that a little bit so.
But and then the bottom line with with sugars is also that you know we want to avoid the simple sugars certainly you know the cookies candies you know white table sugar those types of things.
But whole fruits and vegetables are going to eventually break down into carbohydrates which is you know from sugar and so that can be used as glucose you know to fuel cancer so but when we're eating it in a whole food source we're also getting the fiber the other nutritional benefits from that food so that does offset some of that spike that you would get.
When you're eating just like let's say you're juicing carrots and you're juicing apples so you're not getting that fiber of those other nutrients are just getting the juice that's going to spike the blood sugar higher than when you're eating the whole fruit so whole fruits are preferred.
And you know apples and carrots so it's not a hard science it's not a you know strict yes or no it's it's kind of within reason and so apples and carrots yes they can be higher and sugar if you're diary if your cancer is not being fed directly by sugar you know you can have apples and carrots.
You know I would say you could have apples and carrots every day one apple you know I wouldn't say eat three apples a day but you know a serving and if if your cancer is fueled by sugar I would say okay maybe you know two or three apples a week and you know maybe carrots a couple times a week just don't have them daily don't be juicing these things we want to avoid that spike in the blood sugar.
So it's kind of a great area I know sometimes it's easier for people or people desire to have just black and white just tell me what I should do and I will do it.
And you know if you really want us to do that we can but it really isn't based on science it's just based on opinion so you just have to be reasonable in your approach.
Again if you're eating three to your five apples a day then I would say that's too much if you're eating one apple a day then that's within reason and if you're trying to be more strict on sugar because we've indicated that you need to be then don't have those every day maybe a couple of times a week so I guess that was kind of part of his question here is how often.
Prometheus this is the name of the specific neck tumor so that's kind of funny to to name it but that's that's good you know to just kind of all right this thing here it's what it is and that's what we're going to call it and we are going to attack this thing so.
So so Prometheus is constantly draining and i'm changing the drenched bandage four to five times during the day or night I drink a lot of water during the day and night each night I wake up four to six times a night so yeah so that is is a lot.
So I'm assuming you know you're kind of waking up maybe you're waking up partly to use the restroom so this I guess it's kind of what they're saying.
Two to four times are to go to the bathroom and I drink water before going back to bed.
A couple of times a night I'm he's waking because of foot and shin cramps should I take magnesium to offset the cramps or do you suggest something else so yes you certainly can take magnesium magnesium may want to try.
You know multi mineral so multi mineral or multi mens plus is what we use here sometimes that has a great you know more of a synergistic effect when you're taking.
You know more than just a single mineral when you're taking them all together that can be helpful so.
I would try the multi mens plus and then you certainly can take additional magnesium just be careful magnesium can lead to loose stools but you know for somebody who is constipated that could be a good thing you know I guess not lose stools but helping to you know get the system moving.
And then as far as drinking a bunch of water during the day and drinking water before going back to bed you know obviously great drink water and stay hydrated.
But you know have you had any I know Dr Conner's talked about this on the last zoom call maybe it was the last one or the previous one but somebody had a question about drinking a lot of water and just being so thirsty and he recommended you know checking in with some just general blood work to see.
You know kind of where you know it could be a blood sugar issue going on so you might want to get some blood work done to just test you know is this thirst that you are talking about is it older the range normal maybe you're just drinking water because you're trying to stay hydrated it's not necessarily because you're excessively thirsty.
So if you're excessively thirsty maybe check in with some labs and look at blood sugar levels.
If you're just drinking the water to stay hydrated that's great maybe don't drink so much in the evening time to help eliminate some of these times that you're getting up and going.
Just needing to go to the bathroom hopefully you can fall back asleep relatively quickly but maybe you know try not to drink so much in the evening try to get your water in more during the you know first you know portions of the day you know early after noon and then stop drinking so much.
So try that and then try the the make continue with magnesium try multi men's plus to get more of a wide variety of the minerals so they can work synergistically appetite is low could this be to my body detoxing certainly could when you're detoxing you know you just don't feel like you have energy you could feel.
You could feel achy flu like symptoms loss of appetite absolutely could be because of detoxing and so I guess my question would be how long has your appetite been low is this something new that has happened since you have implemented the knife machine and our protocols or is this something that has been a struggle for a while.
A lot of times just with cancer itself it you know changes the body so you are not you don't have as much of an appetite i'm trying to regain the weight that he's lost so we do have the weight loss kind of excuse me the weight gain healthy weight gain kind of protocol tips and tricks to help gain weight.
So revisit that I know I I sent that to this person it's in their binder but if you need me to send it again I certainly will and really it's just about trying to get high calorie calorie dense foods and so if you can't eat a lot you don't have an appetite you really need to pay attention to what foods you're eating make sure they're calorie dense.
Through avocados and things add coconut oil to things nuts and seeds are you know high in calories really grains are the best way to help the body gain weight to try to regain some weight so eating some healthy grains with every meal.
You know so follow those tips you know you can have add protein to protein powder so try to sip on you know a protein smoothie you know in between your meals even if your meals are not that big you know just really try to get those calories in.
And even just you know putting olive oil on top of foods you know if you've made roasted vegetables just add some extra olive oil on top or add a dollop of coconut oil on top add an avocado on top i'm trying to get those extra calories in.
And then you know maybe try i don't know not everybody can do this but if you can try to lift some some light weights or even just starting out with your body weight you know trying to kind of keep muscles from breaking down you know so to maintain muscles or maybe build a little bit of muscle you know would be good to maybe maybe could stimulate your appetite and then maybe can help you.
You know maintain or gain some weight so lifting some weights look in the binder for the exercise the pages on exercise things that you can do to help with that.
And then certainly you can do a search on our blog i think that doctor Connors has a number of different blog posts and articles just about you know cancer and cakexia and you know if you're losing two to three pounds per week that's you know considered cakexia so we really need to work on that you know i don't think this person is at that point but they just have lost a lot of weight in this process of their cancer journey which is very common.
So try those things that I mentioned and then use that right machine and I know there's an appetite stimulation program on the right machine it might not you know you might try it and I didn't do anything but just keep trying it might be something that you have to use a number of times to kind of stimulate that appetite.
So just keep working at it and see if you can get in a habit that can be helpful reading a chat now i'm news of the program and in schedule for the binder review tomorrow is that one someone will go over my specific findings and protocol with me yes so the binder review i'm assuming you're going to log on at.
The binder review zoom call tomorrow at 11 and yes we will go through questions on the binder or we'll go through your specific testing findings you know if you have specific questions on that a lot of times you know patients do or they they're looking you know for additional information or clarification so yes any binder related questions can be addressed on that binder review zoom call.
And then protocol questions as well so we'll go through kind of the diet recommendations get clarification on what we're asking you specifically to do and then supplements as well we can clarify supplements you know we might have questions on how to take them with food without food we typically are listing in that supplement list when or how.
To take the supplement so if it's not indicated that you're supposed to take it with food then you can assume that it doesn't matter if we indicated you should take it with food then that's how we would prefer you take it but absolutely the binder review session will go over all of those details and welcome i'm glad you're logging on to the Q&A zoom call so that's wonderful and yes you'll get your binder questions answered tomorrow.
And hopefully you'll have some better clarity and you know you'll be ready to go and work your protocol.
All right next question here have you heard of the beamer the bio electromagnetic energy regulation medical device that sends a low intense low intensity pulse electromagnetic field to the body it's a map that you land for eight minutes in the morning and eight minutes at night
the cost is 4,990 it must be on sale it's usually 6 to 500 supposed to enhance blood flow resulting in better oxygen disbursement enhances detoxification strengthens muscle tissue thereby helping all diseases and bodies including cancer thoughts so yes I have heard of the beamer and we have many patients who have.
That equipment and use it and that is great so great therapy if you have it continue to using using it if you're looking to purchase it which obviously this person is.
Doctor Connors believes that our PMF home unit would be a better option I think it's just it's stronger.
You know I guess I don't really know the differences between them I'm not I have heard of the beamer but I'm not super familiar with it so I guess I can't really do an educated comparison but I know that Doctor Connors is very familiar with it and you know kind of the science behind it all and he does prefer the PMF home unit that we have on our website.
So certainly check that out but if you do have a beamer or you decide oh this just sounds better for me it's on sale and so that is definitely cheaper than our home PMF unit so if that's you know what's within the budget then absolutely go for it it is a good therapy and can provide some benefit and absolutely utilize that.
All right her second question is she was in for her annual physical and her physician recommended the pneumococcal pneumonia vaccine said it reduces chances of pneumonia in the elderly elderly psi I guess that's me I don't usually like to take vaccines like this your thoughts so.
Obviously we can't make a recommendation because this falls into the category of you know medical intervention so we have to stay in our lane but I certainly will reiterate my own opinion and you know I agree with your hesitation you don't usually like to take vaccines like this.
And your thoughts my thoughts and so personally my thoughts are you know did you look at the recipient list so when we're taking any time we're injecting something into our body you know we have to pay attention there's things that are in that that are again directly being injected into the body versus is very different to inject something versus consuming something from your diet.
So we have the entire digestive tract that is designed to keep bad things out and let the good things in and so digestion can help get rid of some of you know bad things that are in our food when we are injecting something directly into tissue.
It's in your body there's no you know line of defenses to remove some of those harmful things so vaccines have harmful acceptance in them sometimes there's metals you know aluminum you know in a lot of the vaccines where they're multi dose vaccines they're using mercury.
And so you really need to do your research and look at those recipients now I choose to not put those things in my body and I choose to do other things you know I didn't grow up in you know kind of the alternative mind so I have had vaccines you know and it's just within the last you know 10 years that I really kind of.
You know it's with my husband's cancer diagnosis that you know I've really kind of become awake in some of these areas and really started to pay attention to what we're doing and what we need to be cautious of to try to prevent this from coming back or to help keep this you know under control and so certainly.
I would you know my personal opinion is that I wouldn't you have the right machine the right machine is a great tool to help with all of these things all of these illnesses there's pneumococcal right programs there you know you're you're taking immune stimulating things most of our patients are very aware and conscious and trying to build up health and some most of our patients you know are in a better a better state.
Yeah you know to kind of find things off you know some are are you know pretty sick with their cancer so I guess I can't speak in that general term but really do your research and know what you're putting in your body there can be you know some pretty severe consequences of metals within the body you know look at.
You know the acceptance as far as fetal cell lines and you know how does that you know resonate with your you know your spiritual beliefs so really take a look and you know I tend to hear on the side of your hesitation and just because a doctor says that it can reduce a chance of something doesn't mean that it's right.
And so we believe in obviously an individual approach and no kind of blanket well you know you're at this age you need to get this vaccine because this is the standard protocol well that's not.
It might be fine for some people but it's not good for everyone and especially with someone who has had cancer or currently you know dealing with cancer you just have to pay really special attention because you don't want to tax the body more than it's already being burdened.
You know they're just doing things that you might not want we need the immune system to keep cancer and check all right enough said on that I am on a gluten free diet is it okay to substitute gluten free flour or better off try to use almond flour my recipe for gluten free flour is rice flour potato and tapioca starch with
gum thank you absolutely it's okay to use gluten free flour and you know really I guess it depends if you just use almond flour you're going to get less of the carbs.
Then some of the gluten free flowers that are a blend of some other things like you've listed here so you'll have a little more of that carbohydrate load if you're using that blend but you know if you're not using it very much you're baking with it and so you're having a baked good you know once in a while it's not very often then.
Then then what you're listening is fine and I would just try to get organic sources of those things that you've listed to just make sure they're you know not loaded with herbicides pesticides those types of things not from GMO seed so but yes you can use those blends and you certainly can use almond flour.
All right so that brings us through all of the questions that came in for today and I think I addressed all of the chats that came in.
Any other questions so obviously continue to utilize the patient membership site continue to send in your questions by clicking on the blue submit a question button.
As we've mentioned multiple times we are continuing to add things to the membership site changing things a little bit to kind of clarify things if you know we get feedback that oh I can't find this or this wasn't you know happening correctly we try to to make it more clear and clarify things so so utilize that and give us feedback too.
All right any other questions and then just a reminder that binder review if anybody needs to get on that to a clock or excuse me not to a clock 11 o'clock tomorrow Tuesday so binder review all right everyone well it's been an hour so we'll sign off and I hope you guys have
a wonderful rest of your week and hopefully this was helpful let me know if anything needs to be clarified.
Sometimes I can ramble and maybe not be as clear but let me know and I can clarify or if you need want me to send a link to the apps or anything or if you need the chemo protocol just let me know.
All right everyone have a wonderful rest of your day bye bye and you're welcome thank you.